-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, that's great to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
President Biden said
yesterday that
the U.S. economic recovery
is going to take some time.
Okay, "take some time," like the
Amazon option that saves you
a dollar or "take some time"
like "Avatar 2"?
If he were any more vague,
he'd be a magic eight ball.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said for the
third time yesterday
that the U.S.
would respond militarily
if China tries to invade Taiwan.
Well, at least he's capable
of taking a firm stand
on problems we don't have yet.
Yeah, yeah, we'll fight China!
Student loans?
Uh, yeah, let me call
some people.
In her new memoir, ex-Trump
adviser Kellyanne Conway
acknowledges that former
President Trump
lost the 2020 election.
I know.
I was surprised, too.
However, she does say he lost
to William Howard Taft.
She just can't -- can't help
but get one lie in there.
According to a new report,
ex-Trump attorney Michael Cohen
said in a recent deposition that
former President Trump was
afraid of getting pied in the
face by demonstrators.
I don't know. That feels
like some reverse psychology.
[ Imitating Donald Trump ]
"You know what?
You know what would
totally own me?
If someone threw an entire
freshly baked pie
right in my face.
Even worse, if it had some
of that cinnamon
crumble stuff on top of it.
If they also hit me
with a side of whipped cream,
oh, I would be so delicious --
I mean, embarrassed."
[ Normal voice ] A guitar played
by the late Kurt Cobain
sold in an auction over the
weekend for nearly $5 million.
It's the perfect way to say,
"I don't get what he was
singing about."
[ Laughter ]
That's working at home
with some step-dads right now.
That joke's landing with some
step-dads right now at home,
and I'm willing to suffer
through this moment
with you guys.
But I see you.
[ Whispering ] Step-dads.
Step-dads, I see you.
Sorry about everybody here.
They're doing their own thing.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] The fast food
chain Arby's announced yesterday
that it will add
a hamburger to its menu
for the first time
in its history,
but people don't go to Arby's
because they want a burger.
They go there because everything
else is closed.
[ Laughter ]
Bruce Springsteen
& The E Street Band announced
today that they'll go on
tour next year
after a six-year hiatus.
Though, just to be safe, they're
gonna put a sneeze guard
between Bruce and Stevie.
[ Light laughter ]
[Whispering ] Step-dads.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know why I tried to do
two for you in the same show.
[ Normal voice ] Firefighters in
New Jersey recently removed
a four-foot Monitor lizard
from a tree
in a residential neighborhood.
Isn't that wild?
There's a tree in New Jersey.
[ Laughter ]
Don't shake your head, Wally.
Our cue card, New Jersey's Wally
over on cue cards is like,
"Ohh, trees."
[ Laughter ]
It's just very distracting
to read cue cards when you're
scoffing at the punchline.
-I have two trees in my yard.
-What did you say?
-I have two trees
in my own yard.
-Two trees? Well!
Ol' two-tree Wally.
[ Laughter ]
Are you gonna go to Wally's
two-tree summer party?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, New York City
yesterday removed its last
public payphone from service.
But don't worry,
anywhere else in New York
will still be a public restroom.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We've got a great show
for you tonight.